este es otro de esos acertijos acerca de
personas que tienen que adivinar que
está escrito en su frente y se llama
haber se llama el juego voy a poner aquí
el juego juego de los números en la
frente de los números en la frente en lo
que consiste en lo siguiente el digamos
el dios de los acertijos va a reunir en
un cuarto a tres personas que son
lógicos perfectos déjame escribir esta
cosa entonces le voy a poner por aquí en
otro color que son lógicos perfectos
lo cual quiere decir que tienen poderes
infalibles de lógica y además entre
ellos saben que son lógicos perfectos es
decir cada quien sabe que los otros dos
son lógicos perfectos entonces lo que
vamos a hacer con estos lógicos
perfectos es ponerlos en un círculo
digamos bien visto desde arriba es algo
así es un círculo todos ellos nos van a
quedar calvos pues por pura conveniencia
para que podamos escribir cosas en sus
cabezas esta vez no vamos a marcar
puntos azules ahora lo que vamos a hacer
es escribir un número en la frente de
cada uno de ellos para esto el dios de
los acertijos decide que va a elegir
tres números
números estos números van a ser únicos
es decir todos ellos van a ser distintos
o sea no hay dos de ellos que sean
iguales pues son distintos 2 a 2 todos
ellos van a ser mayores que 0 y una cosa
fundamental es que uno de los números va
a ser la suma de los otros 2 entonces
uno de los números es la suma de los
otros dos va entonces toda esta
información se le da a los lógicos
perfectos vale entonces este es el
método para elegir los números todo esto
se le dice a los tres lógicos y bueno
una vez que se tomen estos números se
escriben en las frentes de ellos y pues
entonces suponiendo que los números son
abc
sin entonces esta última es que ve es
igual hace digamos va entonces además
sabemos que a veces son diferentes que a
es mayor que 0 y que ve es mayor que 0
hay que ser mayor que 0 también verdad
porque es la suma de los dos bueno por
hipótesis pues entonces vamos a
pintarlos aquí aquí voy a poner a acá le
voy a poner p y acá voy a ponerse ok
entonces cuando este bonito
o sea esta es la razón por la cual
pintamos en las frentes de las personas
verdad para que no puedan ver que está
escrito en su propia frente sólo lo que
está escrito en la de las otras dos va
entonces él va a ver ahí ve este bonito
de aquí va a verse y verdad y estoy acá
va a verse y ve va a ver estas dos
frentes entonces estas son las reglas
ahora el monito c pues tampoco le vamos
a dar la información si va a ser la suma
de los dos o sea el de dos números pero
no sabe si su número es la suma o no
pues quién sabe lo único que saben los
lógicos es que alguien tiene la suma de
los otros dos
entonces dadas estas reglas vamos a
suponer que tú eres uno de los
ahora vamos a la vista del jugador así
en primera persona entonces cuando ves a
las otras dos personas déjame dibujar
otra vez unos círculos digamos este es
una persona que tiene como seis dedos de
frente verdad entonces aquí en su frente
lo que ves es pues el número 20 va ok
entonces tú ves el número 20 luego la
siguiente persona que voy a poner con
morado aquí a la derecha ahí está va a
tener escrito un 30 otra vez me quedo
bien cabezón hasta aparecen cabezas
olmecas pero bueno tiene un 30 ahora de
acuerdo con las reglas lo que sucede es
lo siguiente esto de aquí es tu vista
entonces desde aquí estás viendo alguien
que tiene 20 y alguien que tiene 30 pero
el monito de 30 ve lo que está en tu
frente y ve el 20 de la frente del de al
lado y el de 20 el 30 y tu frente va
entonces eso ve cada quien pero ahora el
dios de los acertijos comienza por
preguntarte qué número está escrito en
tu frente
ves a los otros dos
bueno pues no sé yo soy un lógico
perfecto pero aunque soy un lógico
perfecto no tengo la información
suficiente para obtener mi número
el dios dice pues tranquis no hay
problema pasemos al segundo a él le hace
exactamente la misma pregunta le dice
cuál es el número que está en tu frente
entonces él ve a tu número que está a
déjame de dibujar por aquí tú frente ahí
está pero no sabemos que está escrito
aquí va entonces él ve a esta frente y
al 30 pero él también dice no sabes que
no no sé y bueno el dios dice bueno va
se va al tercero al tercero le pregunta
a ver ve a los otros dos y dime cuál es
tu número entonces ve al otro ve tu
frente y dice no sabes que pues yo
tampoco sé después de esto el dios de
los acertijos regresa contigo y te
pregunta lo mismo y tú como un lógico
perfecto dices wow wow yo ya sé cuál es
mi número ok
sabiendo esto la pregunta del acertijo
es la siguiente cuál es tu número y por
qué
es tu número y por qué
por qué
entonces esa de ahí es la pregunta y
cualquier cosa que voy a hacer a partir
de este momento pues va a ser una
sugerencia para resolver el acertijo
entonces si lo quieres intentar ahorita
es el momento adecuado
entonces pues pausa luego piensa le
tantito estoy aquí pues si está más o
menos difícil es un acertijo muy
avanzado pero es muy elemental en el
sentido de que no utiliza matemáticas
muy elevadas o sea no hay ni cálculo ni
matrices ni nada muy involucrado
simplemente pues es es un acertijo como
muy lógico pues de pensar le tantito de
deducir algunas propiedades básicas y
pues con eso debería de salir la
respuesta correcta ok ahora sí vamos a
empezar con las sugerencias vamos aquí
abajo entonces si dibujar otra vez la
vista desde arriba déjame dibujar otra
vez las tres cabecitas ahí estás tú aquí
está el monito que tiene el 20 y aquí
está el otro monito que tiene escrito el
30 el 30 y entonces que sabemos sabemos
que cualquier cosa que está en tu
digamos le pongamos lea a lo que está en
tu frente entonces ya sabemos que a
es mayor que 0 verdad 20 y 30 pues
también obviamente son mayores que 0
ahora sabemos que a no puede ser ni 20 y
30 esto es algo más o menos interesante
pero lo que es más interesante es que el
número de alguien es la suma de los
otros dos va entonces tiene que pasar
una de dos cosas y esto de aquí es la
gran gran sugerencia de lo que voy a
decir ahorita es súper importante ya lo
mejor con esto ya te sale o bien a es la
suma de los otros dos esa es una de las
opciones es decir a es igual a 20 más 30
lo que nos da que a es igual a 50 o bien
hay otra opción o sea 20 y 30 cuando los
sumas esa es una de las opciones verdad
que ya escribimos pero la otra
posibilidad es que 20 más a sea igual a
20 más a es igual a 30 y 20 más 330 es
igual a 10
y por supuesto bueno no puedo decir que
30 más a es igual a 20 porque no puede
ser menos 10 porque princesa es una
hipótesis que teníamos verdad a es mayor
que 0 ok entonces cada uno de estos
jugadores sabe pues una cosa similar
verdad o seamos haciendo un argumento
análogo cualquiera de los otros
jugadores sabe que su número es la suma
o la diferencia por ejemplo este sabe
que su número es es 30 masa o bien sabe
que su número es la diferencia entre 30
ya no sabemos cuál es más grande pero él
sí puede saberlo entonces la otra opción
es que sea el valor absoluto de 30 -
estas son las dos opciones para su
número ahora el tercero sabe que su
número es ya sea 20 más o bien el valor
absoluto de 20 menos a va todo esto
viene de esta observación que hicimos de
que uno de los números es la suma de los
otros dos gracias a esto cada uno de los
jugadores puede reducir a dos
posibilidades su número ok al parecer ya
le sacamos mucho jugo a esta hipótesis
regresemos al enunciado del ejercicio
para ver qué más podemos sacar a partir
de
información entonces nosotros sabemos
que hay 50 o bien que es 10 verdad
entonces al principio nos preguntan cuál
es el número pero como son dos
posibilidades y no tenemos en este
momento más pistas no es posible
determinar a esta altura cuál de los dos
números es verdad ok entonces vamos a
intentar ver qué sucede con la de más
información del problema
entonces nos dice que vamos en círculo
entonces le nos preguntan a nosotros y
nosotros no sabemos por qué porque puede
ser 50 o 10 pero no hay ninguna forma de
saberlo
en este punto verdad hasta ahorita
tenemos muy poca información para
deducirlo pero que más información hay
pues nos vamos al segundo y el segundo
tampoco puede adivinar su número y luego
el tercero tampoco va entonces esa
información parece ser muy importante
entonces vamos a pensar un poquito qué
sucede entonces la situación en la cual
nosotros tenemos 50 entonces vamos a
pensar que a que a es igual a 50 no
sabes que mejor vamos a pensar primero
que a es igual a 10 vas a ver que este
va a ser un caso más bonito entonces qué
pasa si yo tengo escrito un 10 o sea no
lo sé
qué pasaría si lo tuviera escrito
entonces qué pasa con el segundo monito
el segundo monito tiene haberes ya sea
40 porque es 30 10 o bien es 30 menos 10
es decir 20 va entonces pues piensa
tantito y dice de nuevo pues no hay
mucha información porque puedo hacer 40
ó 20 pero no tengo más información al
respecto
entonces vamos al tercer monito el
tercer monito ve que aquí yo tengo un 10
verdad o sea si yo tuviera un 10 él ve
un 20 y un 10 entonces podría tener yo
30 o bien bueno o sea el tercer monito
podría tener 30 o bien 2010 o sea 10
pero dice guau guau espérame tantito a
ver yo no puedo tener un 10 porque si yo
tuviera un 10
entonces el monito de aquí también
tendría 10 y se violarían las reglas
porque una de las reglas es que cada
número es distinto entonces como cada
número es único como cada número es
diferente llegamos a la conclusión de
que si nosotros tuviéramos un 10 eso que
quería decir si nosotros tuviéramos 10
entonces cuando vamos al tercer monito
el monito podría deducir que él tiene un
30 como
para deducir eso pues va otra vez vería
que él tiene un 20 el 20 si lo ve ahora
si nosotros tuviéramos 10 sólo tendría
dos opciones una de ellas es la suma y
la otra es la diferencia la suma sería
30 y la diferencia sería 10 pero él
puede descartar siendo un lógico
perfecto el número 10 porque ya tenemos
nosotros un 10 y todos los números
tienen que ser distintos entonces a él
le toca 30 entonces pues o sea como que
si nosotros tuviéramos 10 llegamos a una
contradicción con las reglas pues bueno
con la información del problema porque
el siendo un lógico perfecto verdad con
toda la información del problema él
podría determinar qué número tiene pero
eso va en contra de lo que nos dice el
problema el problema nos dice que el
tercer monito que el tercero lógico no
puede determinar qué número tiene
entonces pues saber entonces usando la
hipótesis a nuestro favor
quiere decir que o sea si nosotros
teniendo 10 él puede adivinar como él no
puede adivinar nosotros no podemos tener
10 entonces con esto logramos concluir
que nosotros no tenemos 10 y al
descartar la posibilidad de que nosotros
tengamos 10 no nos queda otra opción más
tener escrito en la frente el número 50
una vez más si tuviéramos 10 este monito
podría haber adivinado que número tiene
descartando el 10 de sus únicas dos
posibilidades de la suma 30 y de la
diferencia 10 ya que no puede ser 10
porque si no se repetirían los números
ok esto de aquí fue otro acertijo y el
dios de los acertijos debe estar bien
satisfecho espero que le hayas entendido
pero si no con confianza darle otra re
pasada espero hacer algunos más en
siguientes vídeos